de retour dans les bureaux de vote un an
plus tard la deuxième circonscription
des yvelines a connu en mars 2016 une
législative partielle suite à la
démission de valérie pécresse élue à la
présidence de la région ile de france le
20 mars 2016 c'est pascal thévenot qui
est élu député avec 72% des voix mais
avec seulement 26 % de participation
l'élu les républicains remet son mandat
en jeu avec l'étiquette de favori
la circonscription est
traditionnellement ancrée à droite 17
candidats se sont déclarés pour le
premier tour du 11 juin prochain
le principal adversaire du candidat les
républicains pourrait être jean noël
barrot
l'enseignant chercheur de 34 ans est
actuellement conseiller départemental de
haute loire à la rentrée prochaine et
rejoindra le campus hec de jouy-en-josas
le candidat est investi pour cette
législative par la république en marche
partie des manuels macro mais celui qui
pourrait ravir des voix pascal thévenot
c'est pascale poirot le candidat divers
droite est soutenu par le parti chrétien
démocrate
il se présente pour la première fois
lors de la partielle de 2016 benjamin
lac ont soutenu lui aussi par le pcd
avait obtenu 9 56% des suffrages
autre prétendant le front national
représenté par yasmine benzema et
actuelle conseillère régionale d'île de
france
le parti espère réitérer le score de
2016 où il était arrivé 4e et avait
obtenu 9 38% des voix à noter que dans
cette circonscription le parti
socialiste a trouvé un accord avec
europe ecologie les verts et le parti
radical de gauche pour ne présenter
qu'un seul candidat
et c'est l'avocat tanguy rue et long qui
a été choisie nouveau parti créé lors de
la présidentielle france insoumise a
aussi son candidat l'écrivain et metteur
en scène et acteur marc soriano est un
fidèle de la première heure de jean luc
mélenchon ex candidats sont aussi dans
la course axel brunet candidat divers
gauche christophe pitié pour le parti
animalistes jérémy biz est déjà candidat
en 2016 pour france écologie pascal
casimir perier j pour que le voit
françoise florelle céline julier
emmanuel 2,20 et lenjani c'est jean-guy
ça use et sylvain gargasson le 11 juin
prochain plus de 80 cents mille inscrits
sont appelés à glisser leur bulletin
dans l'urne